bonjour jacques m'ont dit merci de
répondre à nos questions cet après midi
donc d'un côté il y à bedford claude
donc remplacer on vient de le voir par
le tweet qui vient d'être affichés à
l'écran c'est donc le procureur d'un
côté et de l'autre il ya ariel henry lé
premier ministre les deux qui s'accusent
mutuellement qui croire
il faut le reconnaître on est dans une
bataille politique pour la captation du
pouvoir parce que le ph des cas en
l'occurrence le parti du grenelle moïse
a dirigé le pays pendant dix ans et que
les élections devaient s'organiser donc
la disparition du journal moïse faire
d'instrumentalisation à un groupe
politique et de réclamer justice en son
nom mais au fait quand enfin quand il
s'agit d'une manoeuvre politique de
manoeuvres politiques orchestrées par
deux coups il ya un groupe une faction
au sein même de l'appareil partisans du
php k qui veut assurer la continuité et
de joël moïse et il y à un autre groupe
un autre groupe qui au sel ou du php k
mais qui est allé à la solde de l'ancien
président de la république michel
martelly tistes revenir au pouvoir tant
qu'il ya deux camps qui s'affrontent et
que la dépouille de nouvelles moïse sert
de prétexte tout simplement mais ni l'un
ni l'autre ne souhaite avoir justice
toujours une mauvaise parce qu'on voit
bien ils n'ont engagé aucune démarche
sérieuse pour la justice au contraire il
y à tout un ensemble d'opérations vise à
amasser les vrais coupables d'ailleurs
les différents commissaires du
gouvernement totalement les juges
d'instruction qui instruit ces affaires
ne sont pas à la hauteur ils font comme
s'ils souhaitent justice en faveur de
lionel mais au fond c'est une opération
de confiscation du bus confiscation du
pouvoir
le jour où je vais l moïse a été
assassiné il y avait une confusion sur
le nom du premier ministre on souvient
les agences de presse les médias ont
fait de nombreuses rectification même on
parlait de claude joseph qui était
encore en poste qui allait céder sa
place à ariel moïse dans les dans les
heures à venir finale il a pris les
pleins pouvoirs dans l'urgence mais
qu'est ce que prévoit exactement la
constitution haïtienne lorsqu'un
président meurt pendant son mandat qui
prend la présidence par intérim parce
qu'en france si le président de la
république venait à mourir c'est le
président du sénat qui leur le
remplacerait de manière intérimaire donc
là on a vu qu'à une confusion ce moment
là au niveau de la au moment de la mort
de joe mènent moïse will follow en fait
qu'haïti ait fait un cas singulier en
général qui hinault présentant des cas
complexes à résoudre elles mêmes sur le
plan constitutionnel renard qui est fait
qu aucune solution constitutionnelle ni
viable aucune solution litres pourquoi
parce que la fit 140 pages qui croient
le remplacement du président avec le
temps cas de décès et impôts est
appliquée mais sauf que le président de
la république pour certains étaient déjà
en fin de mandat puisqu'il devait il
devait partir le 7 février 2021 d'un
quidam ans le 7 juillet 2011 à terre
autrement dit ils disent à son pouvoir
et a déjà illégitime aux îles à désigner
un premier ministre qui a été nommé mais
qui n'a pas pu être investi avant la
disparition de nouvelles monnaies entre
tavannes premier ministre quand il était
sur le départ donc on s'est retrouvé
avec deux pour les milices un premier
ministre qui a été nommé mais non
investis et un premier ministre
démissionnaire et il était en fonction
donc il ya eu une lutte entre les deux
hommes c'est à dire l'ancien premier
ministre nommé et le communiste qui est
démissionnaire et finalement choix de la
communauté internationale qui a lu
tranché en faveur d'ariel un oui c'est à
dire le premier qui a été nommé par
ronald brise mais qui n'a pas été riche
donc ici on se rend compte de la
provision de l'article s'apparente donc
née maria là où il n'est pas sa place et
a dit le président nommé par ronald
moïse jeunes allemands n'avaient aucune
légitimité pour le désigner michel était
déjà entre mandat alors lui il disait
qu'il devait partie de ce fait au mieux
2021 donc autrement dit on sent tout
avec un homme comme productrice mais qui
n'a ni légitimité ni légalité ce qui
l'attend est de faire là il est
conscient de légitimité à s'allier avec
une partie de l'opposition l'opposition
aujourd'hui est en train de lui donner
et en cette caution cette caution mais
il y a une partie de l'opposition qui
n'est pas d'accord avec
l'opposition parle de la sphère
politique
la population comment elle réagit à tout
ça un premier ministre qui limoges le
chef du parquet
on sait que haïti vit des temps
difficiles un pays gangrené par la
violence par l'instabilité politique par
les catastrophes naturelles les séismes
notamment comment réagit la population à
7 à cette enquête et à ce que vient de
faire le premier ministre la population
réagit d'invités elle observe
cette tragi comédie avec une
indifférence totale puisque les trois
départements du pays à un mois 14 août
ont été mises à genoux par un violent
séisme
mais ce n'est les conditions dans
lesquelles vivent les sinistrés
intéresse les dirigeants de ce pays
coupé en deux oui il ya une crise une
technique évite une partie physique qui
s'occupe la captation du pouvoir est une
il ya une partie de la population qui
vit des heures sombres
puisque tu vives jusqu'à aujourd'hui des
millions de personnes qui vivent sous
des tentes et alors qu'ils sont soumis à
des ouragans violent du ce qu'on vit une
période cyclonique qui va jusqu'en
novembre et dans une indifférence totale
des autorités de port-au-prince donc on
va dire que la population vit avec une
vie austère avec une distance une totale
indifférence sept spectacles qui se
donne à part au pakistan on voit aussi à
7,8 traditionnels pour le bois en haïti
entre les élites et les des victimes
assez souvent ce que moque bien de de la
situation de misère dans laquelle se
trouvent les millions d'âmes souffrance
merci jacques lizé d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue spécialiste d'haïti et
membre du laboratoire caribéen de
sciences sociales